a busy mom doesn't come back like a
visible and I see with clarity like my
name is Gary B Sabah [ __ ] I've
been telling you about
I'll triple they give it a pedigree to
meet in a pleasure my faculties are
putting the work that I'm doing are to
move
[Music]
[Music]
I really love the office and I really
hate yet good I didn't realize how fancy
are loyal we can't find stuff in there
to flip on Facebook marketplace this is
rich and what's the best thing what's
the most challenging thing sounds insane
right an order just make it subjective
call yeah
we have some lovely put some common
ideas and emotions of kind of being
taken off the radar the kind of team you
like highlight for events the vintage
make it right
it's really unbelievable how unemotional
I become about that you know I don't
think we have a waiver from giving the
right advice because that's what our job
is
what can I interpret and I'm curious but
already lost okay my own time my time I
actually love it I want to go right okay
so and you're on Instagram truth is the
way you win in building audiences you
have the right content and you get a
weird you did the lightweight one which
is hashtags it blows me away how many
people don't do that
like that's just so imperative I still
not do it because I was taking for
granted the fact that I have
distribution but even not as expect that
it's lazy let me like do it right but
the way to really do it is every single
down you post a photo
you should be M 30 to 50 people who
potentially may share it now but here's
the key is there's landscape London and
as horn at London and they share [ __ ]
and it's four million followers you to
figure out have actually bring them
value what you do mmm everybody's p.m.
there I get a DM every day like some 500
times so make sure when you see the
accounts and give thought to when you
write when you forward the photo say hey
you know I'm really trying to get some
explode like straight up man right
I'm trying to get some exposure if
there's anything I can help you with
they may look and go oh hey mate once
you give us 10 other photos that will
just use for ourselves we won't even
credit you we need more content and
you'd be thrilled to do that on an
account
900,000 followers that's going to tag
you on your photo that's game good yeah
good luck man yeah we shout anytime yeah
thank you anything that has written
anything from a higher level or anything
that you're curious about
well we've been talking reading and all
about politics in TV I think no but I
think that it's the end of TV for the
people in the media landscape who think
that's the end all be all
you're lucky I think you're more similar
to somebody who was in their 20s and
1940 1950 and watched all these
different changes and then that became
the market for 15 years I think that's
what we'll see a little bit though I
don't think they'll ever be a run
because the technology is going to
change so much and be are coming in 10
15 years on the consumer side so but I
do think YouTube the mountain was
interesting I haven't dug deep into it
but I'm excited about it hi sorry can
you get officially how are things
good thank you good ok I did if you
wrote write it on a wall or like that
I'm you know zinger has always been very
digital forefront even for digital but I
never it's unbelievable how ie never the
only thing I ever worried about if
somebody came from a more traditional
place is that they held subjective
things at a higher regard right but by
the way that happens to digital natives
yes so to me it's not the digital
traditional thing has never filtered in
any other way then she's just holding on
time storage yeah so I'm with you on
that that doesn't leave a certain line
pretty good stuff and everything in this
particular example yes what has me and
yes and we have and we have to be smart
and respect the context from where we
deliver it okay Colton tell me when it
actually going on we know that it does
change how we speak and approach being
it it will say there dude it's cool cool
and so what's your biggest observation
about the difference year than what
you've kind of seen elsewhere and with
anything again before last night that we
might be okay guys okay guys families
Daniella don't get over that compass I
like these London doesn't so much good
yes I take that trip yes a fun so you
know what it's a waste of time it's a
very good job Claire that's exactly and
that's exactly what every friend yes we
are
and it'll be was the only thing that
matters and opinions predicated on
people's insecurities and ego slow [ __ ]
down good for you that's good that's
exactly right I'll give you a good piece
of likes over somebody's number one
nothing changes
humans stay the same so don't don't ever
think the technology is going to make
this human change they're going to adapt
to it but the core principles of human
behavior are very prime and true yes
number two everything takes longer than
you think
in 19th when I was palliative 20 looks
good
so going a little younger when I was 21
22 when I launched winelibrary.com in
1996 i sent by the year 2000 everybody's
going to come into wine library with a
phone that's going to identify smart so
I don't want them that's going to
understand the prices of everything is
what I said and so I better have the
best prices yes it is 2017 you know and
you know it's 21 years later and almost
nobody walks into my store and uses
their smart phone to look up prices
occasionally yeah so AI is right VR is
right the technology's there the
consumer adaption the adoption by the
consumer is what people underestimate me
because it's why we're not using Google
glass and spectacles of scale it's our
behaviors are tough to change they will
over time it I need to run we should
continue this conversation I think
they're I think you're right I think
there is something to be done I get with
you of my inbox
it's Gary vaynermedia let's start
communicating I'll email you back my
cell phone number
I tried thank you right now anything I
can answer you know I was doing moving
there with a big one yes and you know
during my time there that they'd be like
a shipping box like they're taking their
business away from the bigger agencies
that were close to retirement process my
guys let's move them lateral agencies
like so like vaynermedia but he was
going to make media so I just want to
watch
you can be or maybe the A&P model coming
and ex-wife is I don't know I don't care
to be very frank I I just want them to
come to us because we'll be the best
version of whatever it is I think the
pendulum always goes independent
conglomerate independence get bought up
by the conglomerate I think will be the
biggest independent shop in the world
that's it what kind of whether they're
bigger than us or smaller than us but I
think when David and Goliath fight it's
very important that both of them work on
their strengths I think it's crazy when
Goliath loses the David glide should
never lose the David yeah that means bad
strategy
so when word when we're Goliath so like
us versus Luca like if it you was still
doing it I would really make sure we
foot we're [ __ ] huge step on his face
and kill him and it's worth if we're
David because it's us force WPP like get
a [ __ ] rock and put it in this buck
and I like you know so I don't really
care if I'm the big guy or the little
guy I just care to win you know that's
how I think about it like whatever I
have to do I'm always going to do that
that's what I've always done yeah but it
really hits my radar like where you are
like like I don't know why I was like
the other day I was like why do I
actually know what Ryan's up to and like
like and like in life well I'm seeing a
lot of [ __ ] I think I subconsciously am
like filtering and I'm like oh I like
Ryan morning I think absolutely when I
said to myself
myself or mr. Garvey this is little how
are you living on cool go man
no question hey thank you yes sir how
are you I have an office here is where
vaynermedia's offices allow you yeah
yeah yeah how are you what's your name
I'm Brooke that make you be my death on
my way there proof why you would hardly
thank you brother
you're a lesson in command Gary
Vaynerchuk are you ready remember Gary
pH is video yes other photo got us okay
you look good yeah I'm actually going to
Hamburg Germany right now I was here for
like six hours but I'm here often
okay no you did the meeting I'm done I'm
gonna do that I will thank you friend
hello take care of the daily beef heart
was perfect that's the perfect scene for
like the opening the end you know you're
kidding
I knew it by the way I know I knew you
were kidding didn't fall for swear to
God wrapping up the day here in Hamburg
big day tomorrow
Internet rockstars conference excited a
little bit of a chat pretty intense day
let me know like today the same things
Detroit insanely it guessing some weird
waiver in Detroit I guess I'm selling
waiver in New York Detroit in London and
Hamburg all I guess in like a dead end
change so been a while 24 36 hours very
productive really enjoyed my time with
Dan Gilbert and those guys I guess
that's the prior wrap
I guess today right awkward London was
super great at Agra claiming I was in
place but I hit him with the heat off
then I hit him with the first 40k then I
hit him with the main man lot then I hit
him with the ball one by man I hit him
with my whole damn life man I'm giving
them my whole damn mind then I hit him
with the 91 series dusty beats on the
dusty beat man how can I get the BJ like
the tour is when we consume expenses if
it's Benny toxic speed it's the how do
you actually get it walk coming to Manor
spend eleven hours get real detailed on
paid media real details on enforcers
real like like just the B scales of all
the stuff I'm putting on on social in a
being away with experts and write the
content okay I mean ten access right
like what happens when Tony Robbins with
different hours and only Tennessee or
supports me gainers doing a vaynermedia
is going to be doing something similar
to Tiffany and and us and zappers which
is tour and consulting for today at
Vayner media so come in at 8:00 a.m.
leave at 7:00 p.m. eleven hours ten
thousand dollars ahead you get toward
the office and then you get eleven hours
of content in detail you know
influence of marketing video production
strategy
workshops jamming only 10 people out of
time
get the Boehner experience and a digital
marketing day that I'm trying to go how
to make ry+ of building it we're doing a
bunch of stuff we're going to interview
all of you one by one so they get
content out of it the manifest okay
we're getting close today can you get
that done because we have pieces right
let's put a massive video called how how
to start so many of you were stuck
haven't started your thing but uh we're
going to be lab shuttle run to the
airport because well Humber Germany on
my my way London thank you for the 50
hours Detroit thank you for the two
hours and oh your Island
the Irish keynote is up and it is a
beast if you have not seen my keynote
from Dublin here missing all that you've
got out enter better give you respect to
the point of no acknowledgement plug
yourself you better that's a plate of
bread and now just getting to honorable
really kind of stuffy wrinkly a little
bit in front ever sowed venture have to
start recording radio micro lot of
action is flown today for mayor full
data for de aeropuerto hotels hotel get
became a lot a lot of focus on the
product offerings for the intermediate
clients crafty stuff a lot of our
revenue realization nerdy different
stuff of running if you know and
sometimes when you guys watch this you
forget that I'm running you know 100 and
now it's pure while giving 150 million
dollars plus longer with the interact so
pretty busy every day is the day the
crunch a day closer to the real life a
day closer to the recognized I'm very
well be the guy manacles every will be
begun lord knows it's a matter of a
touch